alright we are here at San Diego with
Jim lean Rob Williams we are going to
talk Suicide Squad so how excited are
you guys about this sorry how excited
are you I'm very excited as well uh yeah
it's it's really cool to be working on
the book it's right around the corner
now and you know we're at you know I've
very curious how the fans will react i
think there's some stuff that has never
been explored with the squad some of the
interpersonal relationships and we've
devoted a fair amount of time to that
and rob has some really cool bits in
there so i think it's going to be a lot
of fun to see their reaction to what's
been created yeah i need stir you know
it's an all-action thing it's just the
first issue sort of launches with what
you know we're straight into the suicide
part of the Suicide Squad you know
they're going on a mission that you know
is absolutely lethal and pitch thrown
into it Jim's making it look awesome and
yeah I mean it's put on this great time
as well you know we're coming out with
the movie and everyone seems very you
know pumped about that so yeah it's a
the we think people are like it we hope
people now I know back at wondercon one
was announced you two mentioned it you
didn't see the movie yet has either you
seen a movie are you still trying to
absolutely bits and pieces so you should
find Dan I know Danis yeah so there was
time to see it and I passed on the
opportunity because I didn't want to get
too much of my head and I already was
from just even looking at the trailers I
think there's a danger that you might
get so excited about what's the movie
that also now the comic kind of mirrors
the movie too closely and I don't you
know i'm gonna say it's dangerous but i
think it's important for the comm book
to have its own identity if you look at
our entire line the stuff that does well
when there is a movie adaptation is not
the stuff that slavishly or is an apt
ation of the work itself it's the stuff
that are good stories in above
themselves and at this point fans and
readers of all media know that if you
find the source work to something it's
not going to be a 101 you know it's not
gonna be a one-to-one translation of
what they just saw as a film in fact
they probably would be disappointed that
were the case there they know that if
they buy a game of thrones the book
there
read something different than what
they've experienced on the TV show
itself and so I think it's important to
kind of deliver something that is
creatively different and cool and
unusual and stands on its own but now we
saw a page from the comic and
specifically we saw Amanda Waller in the
new 52 she kind of got a makeover in the
the page that was released and she's
looking a little closer to her pre new
52 anything you want to talk about that
or is at a wait and see is that a pun OS
oh yeah no I think no it's I think when
we did the April full special with
Harlequin we made a conscious choice to
do kind of a pre 52 look for the
character we felt that was more
representative the iconic version of the
character but it's not a reboot of the
character I mean it's just a weight
change so it does happen so underscores
the diversity we seek to have in the
line I mean woman of color a different
body type but obviously very very
powerful with in DC Universe and one of
the things to do visually in the first
issue is is kind of show that she I mean
she's nicknamed the wall for both her
authority she represents the line
between good and evil but also as a
physical force she's this wall of a
person but also then I would draw her
kind of smaller compared to her soldiers
or the bodyguards that she that would
accompany her to show that this
Authority this power comes from from her
command it comes from her personality
her presence not and so it's it allows
us to play with a lot of different
themes at once now what's it like
writing a book of villains basically and
trying to get people to read the book
because and basically root for the
villains you know is it a different
mindset to make sure they don't feel too
bad rooting for the bad guys uh oh I
don't mind I don't feel bad about that
at all nothing slyest no that's that's
part of the fun of the book you know and
very often villains are the most
interesting characters that's true you
know in all kinds of stories definitely
in this case you know they've got their
frailties of the to the floor and it's
their Freight people's for
lt's usually make them interesting yeah
if someone's just clean cut across the
line you know it it's tough to sometimes
to deuce interesting stories with those
carriers Suicide Squad doesn't seem to
have any of those problems these guys
are like scumbags that would like with
trailer says the worst of the worst but
what you have to do is humanize them you
have they've all got everyone's the hero
in their own story and that's a really
important the thing you'll see coming
forward you know these guys they feel
put upon by the underdogs and then they
get put into appalling situations you
know so I think it's easy to root for
them they you know they get a raw deal
even though if you let them out they
probably carve you up you know what I
mean okay last question now with with
such a big cast and you know we can
assume that Harley and that shadow
probably at a lot of the spotlight but
how are you going to dress the others it
can be in the back up so make sure
everyone gets equal you know page time I
that's one of the interesting things
about I mean you've got a loaded teen
books over years I mean I one of the
interesting things is giving everyone
their moment you know and trying to give
it weight and sort of the but I mean
we're doing the back up stories as well
which kind of allows us to show the
background and and and get to the heart
of the characters so is that but really
you want the main story geminis main
story to sort of do that for you those
are good that's going to be the big
dramatic beats that's going to be where
people have put in peril and people
gonna have to make sacrifices and all
the things exam make people emotionally
connect with the characters what stories
are broken down into a main story about
12 pages and then a backup story that
will focus on individual sort of
personnel files of focus on individual
squad members about seven or eight pages
and they'll give robbed opportunity to
to give everyone their due but I would
also say that within the main context of
the story it's not necessarily the
amount of real estate you have in the
story it's what you do with the time
that the cameras essentially on you and
so there's some really cool bits i think
that are very short nature but really
make you go like that's a cool character
i would love to hang out with that you
know that character so there's a lot of
fun stuff like that and also work in an
art is phillip tannin and jason fabok is
that true hey buck so Jason Fey box
doing the back up to the first issue and
I think Philip is also doing some
backups because we changed the format
to to accommodate the schedule and try
to do something a little different with
the platooning of artists if you notice
across the rebirth line sometimes you
see multiple artists do in the same book
and then like Wonder Woman you see one
artist do in the contemporary storyline
another artist doing the year one
flashbacks in between every other issue
so with Suicide Squad given the nature
of the characters the the desire to see
more of the background of the individual
squad members we felt that having a main
story with a backup story allow me to do
the main story on that schedule and
allow us to bring some really awesome
superstar artists like Jason to come in
and do backup stories and let them I
mean everyone loves the squad everyone
has a favorite character of theirs and
allows them to come in and work with Rob
and do something really cool that kind
of shines the spotlight and gives those
characters there they're due in the
spotlight okay I lied last question was
Harley did you see said before Harley
was your favorite to work I know I did I
never said it maybe I did no I don't
think so i don't maybe someone else
maybe another Gimli no I don't have a
particular favorite cousin a team book
you have to you have to love all the
children equally right so but what you
find in you know you you read the script
you start drawing it and things start
you start seeing connections both
visually and through the dialogue and go
like hey this character would get along
with this character or this character
would find comfort with this other
character and this character would annoy
the hell out of this other character
right so that's the fun stuff and so you
kind of need them all to have that to
have that situation I you know if you
just focus on one or two I think it's
not really a team book Jim's right but i
love captain boomerang that's right
everything you said is absolutely right
but i love captain boomerang because
he's the worst of a lot of them and the
worst is just the best to write
sometimes the most fun he can save her
things and no one else in the team will
say and that's kind of freeing you know
okay so Suicide Squad rebirth number one
in August and then you so you got to get
back to drawing right so the rebirth
issues august 3rd i believe that
wednesday and then suicide squad number
one is august seventeenth okay so okay
the drunk i think i have my hit pages
make sure you guys pick that up
you